welcome back everyone I'm James Murphy
python 312 has just released here's my
take on all the latest and greatest my
company's M coding we do software
Consulting check us out at M
coding. fans of static typing will be
pleased to know about the biggest change
in Python 312 the new syntax for type
parameters and the type statement when
defining a generic function in Python
you can now declare any type variables
for the function in Brackets like this
previously you would have had to import
type bar from the typing library and
then create your own type variable like
this making sure that the name that you
assign it to matches the name and quotes
here that's no longer necessary just put
brackets T you could also put multiple
type variables like this type bar tuples
like this and param specs like this you
could also constrain the allowed types
like this or like this this syntax is
even more convenient for defining
generic
classes previously defining generic
classes was very
confusing you have to import stuff and
Define your own type variables
and then you have to learn about
category Theory and pick the right type
of variance for your type variable that
used to be super annoying and confusing
but thanks to python 312 it's now no
longer
necessary you don't even have to know
about covariant anymore python just does
the right thing it automatically
determines it you can now also use the
type keyword to Define your own type
aliases you could sort of already do
this by declaring a type Alias like this
but this usage is
deprecated and notice that this type
Alias is find before expected is toin
that's fine these type aliases are
evaluated lazily and they can even be
generic to go wild this new syntax is
going to make generics in Python a lot
less cumbersome to write so if you love
static typing I rate this 8 out of 10 if
you hate static typing I'll still rate
it three out of 10 next up pep 701 F
strings are now officially formally part
of the Python
grammar for historical reasons they used
to be implemented in a kind of hacky way
one of the consequences of that hack is
that you couldn't use the same kind of
quotes that started the F string inside
one of the fing Expressions without
escaping python would see that quote and
think you're trying to end the F string
in an unbalanced way well no more you
can now put whatever expression you want
inside an F string including another F
string but of course just because you
can doesn't mean you should keep things
readable all around this is a great
update that gets rid of an ugly wart
that python had 9 out of 10 next up pep
684 a unique per interpreter Gill did
you know you can have multiple python
interpreters in the same process even in
the same thread here an interpreter
means the part of python that runs in a
loop reading and executing python bite
code the main purpose of a sub
interpreter is to provide isolation each
sub interpreter is like a little sandbox
that can execute code independently from
the other interpreters it has its own
globals Imports
Etc an example usage is something like
mod whiskey for security reasons a web
server serving multiple different
applications should keep data for each
application separate therefore mod
whiskey creates a sub interpreter for
each application group when a request
comes in a worker will acquire and use
the sub interpreter dedicated to that
application group so where does Pep 648
come in well python has this thing
called the Gill the global interpreter
lock but that also means python is
limited in multi-threaded performance
because only the thread that currently
holds the Gil can actually run python
code while sub interpreters do provide
isolation there's still a small amount
of State that's shared between them and
in particular the Gill is or was shared
between them this pep makes it so each
interpreter gets its own Gill which will
allow True multi-threaded Performance in
Python for the very small number of
projects that actually use sub
interpreters in summary a per
interpreter Gill is a great idea it just
only applies to a few projects so six
out of 10 have you ever tried debugging
your python application and found it to
be unbearably slow compared to when you
just run it
normally introducing pep 66 9 low impact
monitoring well here's a direct quote
from the pep by using quickening we
expect that code run under a debugger on
312 should outperform code run without a
debugger on 311 previously python
debuggers worked using cy. setet trce
which allows essentially the same
functionality in a less efficient way
the new CIS monitoring namespace
provides a clean API to register for
events and the implementation details
allow it to take advantage of the
ongoing work of specializing
instructions at runtime quickening as it
was mentioned before is the process of
replacing slow instructions with faster
specialized versions at runtime this is
all part of the faster cpython project
link below anyway better debugging I'm
definitely in 8 out of 10 next up better
error messages particularly for common
typos did you forget a self dot
somewhere or use the wrong Syntax for an
import now python will tell you exactly
what you did wrong these are small
changes but literally every developer
benefits from from better error messages
10 out of
10 I yes Pep 683 Immortal objects this
is a juicy one do you run ajango app
with over 2 billion monthly active users
if so this is the most exciting python
312 update for you you see if you have
two billion users you're going to need
to Fork a lot of worker processes to
handle all those requests they generate
good thing forking is so fast on Linux
because it uses copy on right but
wouldn't it just be a darn shame if
every read in Python was also a right oh
wait every read in Python is also a
right because when you read a python
object first you increase its ref count
that's a
right too bad that's going to trash your
cash and ruin your day introducing
Immortal objects twiddle one of those
High bits in an object's ref count and
poof it's now Immortal Immortal objects
do not participate in ref counting
because they're meant to live forever at
least until interpreter shut down
there's no point in keeping track of how
many people have references to none true
false and other Global immutable
built-ins make them Immortal to with
Immortals now you can have a read it's
really just a read two out of 10 I don't
have 2 billion monthly active users next
up pep 709 comprehension in lining
previously dictionary list and set
comprehensions like these were defined
under the hood using functions meaning
it literally compiles the inside of a
comprehension as a separate function
which it then instantiates and calls
immediately that creates a bit of
overhead because you now have to create
this function object and create a stack
frame when you call the function well
that's no more they change the
implementation dictionary list and set
comprehensions no longer use functions
under the hood all the comprehensions
get compiled inline inside this function
hopefully you won't really notice this
change you'll get a slightly different
traceback if you have an exception
inside a comprehension because there's
no longer this stack frame associated
with the comprehension and since
comprehensions are now compiled inline
you can now see the local variables of
the outer function with a call to locals
as opposed to the local variables of
that inner Lambda function scope I mean
it's a tiny Improvement but why not six
out of 10 next up pep 688 using the
buffer protocol from python the buffer
protocol is a common interface allowing
many libraries like numpy to
interoperate as long as they can
conceptualize their data storage as some
kind of n-dimensional array determined
by a few properties like the number of
Dimensions shape strides and element
size previously the buffer interface was
only accessible in the cap API
this pep exposes that interface to
python by adding two new magic Dunder
methods Dunder buffer and Dunder release
buffer the usefulness of buffers in
Python is limited but it could be useful
for debugging or potentially building a
bridge type that connects to C
extensions H I probably won't use it
four out of
10 next up pep 692 using type stick to
annotate quars the default way that you
annotate keyword arguments in Python is
not very intuitive guars is always going
to be a dictionary and the keys of the
the dictionary are always going to be
strings so originally python decided
that that means you just need to
annotate the value type so if I annotate
quars as an in this means that it's a
dictionary of string to int that's
already confusing enough but also when
would I want just an arbitrary number of
extra keyword arguments that all have to
be integers if you have a use case I'd
love to hear your thoughts comment below
if I was going to take a bunch of
keyword arguments I'd probably want them
to have some specific structure a typed
dictionary seems like a perfect match
for defining the structure of a
dictionary so why don't use that we
can't just typeint quars as a movie
because remember that's going to be
interpreted as a dictionary of strings
to movies well in 312 they added unpack
into the typing Library which instructs
the type Checker to do what you would
hope it would do namely treat quars like
it's supposed to be one of these type
dictionaries I'll give it four out of 10
I guess I would really prefer to do this
instead of using quars but quars are
part of the language so we should at
least be able to type them properly
next up developers who are paid by the
line of code are going to love this one
pep 698 the typing override
decorator let's say you have a class
hierarchy we have a base class shape
that has a cal area method then we have
squares and triangles that are both
shapes both square and triangle have
their own specialized way of calculating
their area the programmer then uses the
override decorator to signal that yes
this implementation of calc area is
meant to be an override of something in
a base class this doesn't really do much
at runtime but when we run our type
Checker we find a problem the method
used to be called get area but we did a
big refactor and it's now called Cal
area but it looks like we missed a spot
and there's still a get area floating
around the base class may have even had
a correct albeit slower implementation
of calc area for the triangle so
potentially all of our tests still pass
but because this method is marked
override and there's no get area
function left in the parent class this
now becomes a type error that we can
catch at static analysis time there's
also a suggested strict mode that would
make it a type error if you didn't mark
the function as override when it was
overriding something in a base class
this could potentially stop you from
accidentally overriding something in a
base class that you didn't know existed
in the first place my only fear is this
might be the second step along the way
to becoming C++ with their public static
conext per autoc const override that you
need to slap on every definition
hopefully it won't come to that 5 out of
10 next up pep 689 introducing the
unstable C API tier Lots about the C API
in this release huh this pep introduces
the unstable API which has the same
compatibility requirements as the public
API but does not require deprecation
warnings before change so this contains
things that are basically expected to
change with every version of python this
would be useful for something like a
debugger that might use specific op
codes that are only valid in specific
versions of python currently everything
the stable tier is related to code
objects so unless you're using the Capi
this probably won't affect you but good
to be aware 6 out of
10 and the most painful change not even
a pep for this one setup tools is no
longer included by default in a virtual
n this change is undoubtedly going to
break some people's builds setup tools
has been the default and deao standard
for building and packaging your python
code for a long time now and many people
generally expect it to be there with
that said setup tools is no longer the
only build system for Python and it
doesn't make sense to pre-install it pip
still works even if setup tools is not
installed but it's still painful to
break someone's build so I'll give it a
1 out of 10 but ultimately I do agree
with the PIP team that this needed to be
done eventually there's also a ton of
tiny improvements to many libraries but
I'm not going through all those let me
just mention my favorite gem iter tools.
batched 10 out of 10 I rate batched over
and over again it's in like 80% of my
code bases glad to see it includ
included in the standard Library all it
does is split in iterable into batches
of a fixed size in this case three so I
get 1 2 3 4 5 6 except the last one
might be shorter and finally saving the
best for last the absolute most awesome
part of python 312 being released is
that python 37 is now past its end of
life and I can drop support for it in
all of my code bases and python 38 has a
year to go so I can start pushing
clients to upgrade to
39 again I'm James Murphy don't forget
to check out my Consulting Services ATM
coding. thanks to my patrons and donors
see you in the next
one